Instead of creating a bunch of random
trees, the boosted model makes one tree.
The boosted model's algorithm performs
an analysis on the errors of the tree to
identify the biggest source of error.
Then it changes the tree to reduce that
error and then it does the analysis
again to find the next biggest error and
then it makes changes to reduce it.
It does this over and over again until
it can't make the tree any better and
then we have a finished boosted model.
To learn more of the mathematical
foundation of this model,
just check out some links
in the reading notes.
Now we will go ahead and
build out a boost model over in Altrex.